foreign
[Music]
what features and best practices you
should use to simplify development then
stay tuned hi I'm Chloe and in this
video I'll be sharing six useful
features to consider using when working
with Pub sub let's get started
number one push subscription
using push subscription can be useful in
the following scenarios
if you're not able to include any code
in your subscriber application
if your subscriber is not allowed to
make any outgoing requests or in cases
where you want to use one instance to
process messages from various topics and
subscriptions where the subscriber
client doesn't have context
number two
seek
you can use the seek feature to replay a
message in Pub sub by seeking to a
snapshot or timestamp seek lets you mark
previously acknowledged messages as
unacknowledged this allows you to force
Pub sub to redeliver messages in
instances where you may have performed
an erroneous acknowledgment you can also
use seek to delete the unacknowledged
messages by seeking a future timestamp
number three message retention in topic
enable topic retention to store messages
in the topic regardless of if you're
ready to consume them or not you can
retain messages in a topic for up to 31
days
number four message retention in
subscription
you can also retain acknowledged
messages in a subscription by enabling
subscription retention or by taking a
snapshot
you can retain messages in a
subscription for up to seven days when
the message retention period set on your
topic does not match the message
retention period set on your
subscription messages will be retained
up to the grader of the two
number five dead letter topic
consider setting up a dead letter topic
allowing Cloud Pub sub to forward
undeliverable messages to it
you can move messages from the dead
letter topic to your original topic by
using a data flow pipeline to move
messages from dead letter topic to your
topic
updating an existing pipeline to read
from both the original topic and dead
letter topic based on configuration or
by creating a new system that when
enabled moves messages from one topic to
another
number six configure by region
if you have data residency requirements
you can configure Cloud Pub sub to Only
Store messages in certain allowed
regions
Pub sub's topic message storage policy
offers a way to ensure that messages
published to a topic are never persisted
outside of a set of Google Cloud regions
you specify regardless of where the
publish requests originate
there you have it six useful features to
consider when working with Pub sub
take a look at our Pub sub documentation
for even more tips and tricks and check
out the description below for links to
additional information as well as
step-by-step guides on the tools
discussed in this video
foreign
[Music]